Mike did you try to pitch to any
organizations about getting sponsorship
for the documentary yeah i think you
know nowadays there's so many grant
opportunities and organizations that
help documentary one is the ifp doc lab
we tried you know we submitted our our
project to the doc lab and just weren't
quite the 10 you know of the 10 products
they picked so and that was tough
because once you get rejected it's like
just puts you in a state of just mmm
just don't know what to do next after
you get that rejection so what was
interesting is after we shot the film we
actually got out to the power to the
pixel event that's out in London and we
were part of this pixel pitch and so
every year now they have a collection of
films where they do a pitch and we were
part of that inaugural year we're
basically yeah you show something of
your project and in theory there's a lot
of distributors or investors that are
there at the pixel pitch so that was
that was an amazing opportunity I
wouldn't say anything came from it as
far as people being involved in people
investing in the project but you know
our projects very unique it's very
interesting it's this massive
collaboration of people at this crazy
one week experience and you know you
don't really know you don't really know
why companies or different organizations
don't get involved you know you you
reach out you think you've tried you
think you've made the effort to try to
get people involved but ultimately this
project is participatory and so anyone
can be involved if they want to be
involved is kind of the the mojo the
project what other work did you do in
terms of trying to reach out to
organizations I mean did you just find
like natural food companies or RV come
to different things that were in line
with what may take place at Burning Man
well yeah I mean it's a it's a fine line
because basically burning man has a
principle of D commodification which is
the idea that's sort of like let's not
exchange money you know let's let's
let's participate in the gift economy
right which is sort of like a natural
flow of giving and so there's no ads out
there there's no sponsors out there the
only thing really that you can buy is
ice you know they'll sell you ice and
and coffee you know and that's to
survive you got to keep your food cold
out there and stuff like that so
everything else is just free and open
and even things like logos will get
covered up out there people that rent
like budget trucks or u haul trailers
that will actually cover up the
advertisements or the logos so as far as
getting sponsorship in that way for the
project it's kind of frowned upon I mean
getting Coleman tents to sponsor getting
cannon to sponsor it because we use
their cameras it feels too much like you
know sort of like it not having the
right feel to it and so yeah we just
stuck with you know our own thing and
and did it like that
you